multiple women know
but yeah
that's that's your jealousy that is
jealousy yeah that's your jealousy you
need to need to work with you
i'm gonna love someone too yeah but you
need to work on your jealousy no it's
about equality isn't it you live another
is though we don't live in an equal
society love someone else too while he
loves me i'm gonna find the men that i
love too it's about equality but like we
said earlier on
you are fine with double standards that
benefit you
you're fine with double standards that
benefit you
yeah but that will benefit you as well
what maybe me being with one woman sorry
i express myself uh not in a right way
i'm saying
you are
you are ben fitting benefiting
uh of multiple women and while i'm with
a man that he's been with his dick sorry
for the expression but we have to be
real
in another people's you know
vaginas
and then you come back to me you're
right thank you
jealousy again
um i just think
it's not jealousy it's jealousy it's not
jealousy i don't care about like if you
are with me you are with me you are not
gonna go jump in another woman knowing
that you have
then we are cool about it because you
love two or three women at the same time
and then you come back to me in the same
day or the next day and you know and
that's okay and that's jealousy it's not
jealousy it's it's dirty it's disgusting
it's just okay how do you feel let's
reverse
how do you feel like you accept that for
yourself right so now no i'm not saying
that this is my life i'm just actually
just like expressing that yeah okay but
no jealousy right okay so how do you
feel me loving another man while i love
you then
if you were my woman that wouldn't
happen i would say go to him
because we're not wired the same the
point is like i don't know it's not
quite the same advocating for men to ch
i don't i people know i'm not advocating
for cheating advocates
i'm just saying but but but the thing is
like we have to accept that we're
different right and so you say oh that's
gross that's disgusting
yes yeah they do she in the same way
you're right that's true
yes like you talk about in a nature way
biological way and you need to respect
that because that's biological you guys
have to respect as well and understand
biological as well it comes to women and
that's biological
oops
oops you know you know what's
interesting about equality i just feel
like women i'm back here sorry is is
that in any relationship there's always
someone like even in female friendships
there it's never equal there's always
one leader and one follower i disagree
me and my best friend are two equals so
you think in women groups there's always
an ugly friend no
no me and my best friend are both
stunning
don't no honestly
everyone says yeah there's always ugly
friends there isn't it doesn't even have
to be about looks it's just about like
one person makes decisions more than
others
it's i i you might be maybe i should
maybe we're just the exception you you
might you seem to be the exception to
everything today well which is good
that's good not bad at all stop the cap
i said let's stop the game i love
pictures of me and my best friends
oh wait we're gonna have the chat to
break them
yeah if we send people to rank you and
your friends yeah if you want you you
can put a picture of the friend in the
chat but everyone's always gonna have
their own opinions but what i'm saying
is that's always with the pretty friends
remember we said before like why do
women lie to each other like women lie
to each other very well you know they
lie to each other very well
like i i don't understand it but i i see
it like men
men in in a male group of and in a group
of guys guys who know the guy that's
like the shortest one maybe the one
that's like doesn't get the most girls
and all this kind of stuff guys were
like yeah cool but the thing is he will
know that that's who he is
right women
tell you're a 10 girl you're amazing
you're it's like stop lying because the
results do not oh my gosh the results
aren't the same i mean
i've been in this situation where like i
know my friend is like more attractive
than me right and it's not it's not like
the end of the world like sometimes
people are just better looking than you
right but i'll tell the girls this i'm
like oh like they're talking to she's
like oh no they're trying to talk to you
too i'm like stop lying
this man asked me about my friend i'm
like the audacity
yeah
all right
because she like came by and he's like
who is your oh what the
hell but like look at it like but we
were like yeah you look great you're
fine you're a 10. yeah they lie to one
another whereas men don't have did we
the thing is men are quite realistic
like they're just more realistic and the
thing is because
yeah but we and we don't take things
personally we kind of understand our our
level in like
the way yeah we understand in the
hierarchy thank you very much like we
understand it but women tend to think oh
all of my girls are you asking about a
friend oh she's great she's amazing
she's this it's like why the [ __ ] you
lying why why why are you lying because
you know the results don't say that
you know that the guys when you go out
are not all going at your friends do you
know the guys that all the pro you know
they're approaching you maybe but you
know they're not all approaching your
friend so why are you lying
why are you like you want to be nice
right exactly
don't attack no i'm just saying i'm not
trying to attack i'm just saying men are
just more realistic yeah yeah for sure
so yeah when it comes to feminism i
think to answer your question pearl um
yeah feminism is not needed in the
western world right now because things
are quote-unquote equal now
and women are not women don't have any
rights that men don't have
um the you've shown that the pay gap
um
is a nonsense doesn't make any sense so
yeah what is a need for feminism right
now except for
hating men
who are you jess end of the show
um
i i don't think it's necessary
i think like i said earlier it
teaches like the main thing is to be
independent and if women want to
have a relationship at the end of the
day
it hinders them in a way and
it doesn't
feminism doesn't talk about the facts
like you stated like at 30. 90 of your
eggs out the dough
and your percentage of just
being with someone that you
want to be with it goes down as you get
older and for someone like me i'm like
i'm almost 30 and my window is closing
and so if
i feel like if that was something that
was taught
then
more women would understand like yes i
need to be independent but there's going
to come a time where i need to start
putting myself out there putting myself
in situations to be able to
find that suitor that i want so i don't
i don't think it's
necessary okay
we've got honesty